Corey to start let's just address what
the skeptics are saying what is the
point of the Apple watch it was clear
the appeal of the iphone the internet in
your pocket and iPad looked like it took
you know crossover between a macbook and
and iPhone who wants an Apple watch
what's gonna do for me well I living
first distance myself from the fanboy
cited they're far too vociferous for me
I look I think I don't think it was
clear when the phone was lodged that the
world needed another smartphone I don't
think it was clear when the kindle was
lower when the window when the ipad slot
was launching another ereader right it
was going to the apple ii reader so what
this watch will be and what its ultimate
uses will be I think our it's reasonable
to question that and I think when we
look back at what happened with those
earlier launches we can start to see
that if you look at what happened when
the first iPhone came out the initial
sales were robust but you know a drop in
the bucket of what we were to see in the
later years similarly once the business
had been built up around the ipod and
the iphone it didn't seem like even
after its first and second year that the
ipad numbers were going to be that big
that took a few years as well so I I
don't think the first year is telling
really is going to matter a lot when it
bites of the Apple watch Cory is this
the first fully Tim Cook product or did
Steve Jobs still have a hand in this
probably steve was a little bit involved
but this is very Tim cookie right Tim we
know to him as a fitness guy we know
that he's a guy who's personally focused
on personal health as if it's a passion
of his famous for walking quickly around
the Apple headquarters he's famous for
always having probably chewing on some
kind of power Bauer energy bar and
having a water bottle with him he talks
about is exercising does meetings all
the time on his bike so this is
something that resonates with him in
particular and I think that's one of the
reasons they're making a fitness such a
focus right probably uh some of my
sources tell me that Fitness me a big
focus of today's announcement Corey
Johnson the bad news is you grew up in
Rochester New York where everybody put
their Instamatic sup on the shelf in the
closet after one year here's the way it
works a toy comes out everybody goes
gaga
the real test is does it go back up on
the shelf in the closet or you give it
off to you know some kid who mowed the
lawn that's how I got my first camera is
the iWatch going to be a dog that Corey
Johnson's gonna put on a shelf of the
closet so I you know I think the
question is functionality and this
really gets to what Tim Cook talked
about a few weeks of the goldman sachs
conference about the Apple watch is that
they don't really know what people are
going to do is they have their sessions
or encouraging development but that they
really think that the the functionality
with the phone with Apple pay might make
this somewhat different you know like a
frozen i'm reading wearing the jawbone
up right now and i wear this thing
religiously but typically people who are
getting the up and the Fitbit they tend
to wear these things for six months nine
months and move on to something yes so
there will be a challenge for them to
keep this a functionality i think that's
why fashion is a big part of the phone
okay as well Olivia jump in here I want
to know what you think the wall street
journal talks about Tim Cook's gonna be
a Rolex company I'm like come on I was
in the apple store this week and
nobody's being Rolex they're just buying
toys aqui yeah it's wired that's a great
prank Corey I've also read many articles
about Apple trying to position itself as
sort of a low end luxury goods company
do you agree with that well I think that
the the notion that Apple's better than
the next thing override that an apple
phone is significantly brand more
important than a samsung phone that has
similar functionality and that's helped
them in all markets not just in China
but in the US market as well so
attaching themselves to the fancy side
of things put in the first ads in broke
not in popular mechanics that matters to
them that helps them sell more devices
of every kind okay I'm going around the
room right now Olivia are you buying one
no Cory are you buying one I said I
wouldn't buy an iphone I said I wouldn't
buy an ipad okay I'm gonna find a giro
showing I want to ask you you're not
gonna buy on Victor you can buy one
victor victor says no he's not gonna buy
one either we're like 0 for 5 on the TV
set i Corey Johnson thank you so much
Corey Johnson will be at the event in
cupertino california bringing you live
coverage on a 22 hour work day we
appreciate you Corey Johnson